what's going on reject Nations Greg Alba
here and it's John over here we're going
to watch the trailer today for Netflix's
gypsy movie oh boy before we do that or
it's not a movie I think it's a TV
series miniseries actually well before
we do that actually I wanted to give a
mention to a sponsor friend because we
are sued confidant the rehab there's
this app called TV time that when we
given mentioned to it a week or two ago
we found out that like there's a lot of
people on this channel that watch the
channel that are already using the app
and it's this really cool app that I've
been using frequently I've actually been
using the app frequently yeah helps keep
track of all the TV shows you've ever
watched you can bookmark them and all
the seasons the latest episodes you've
seen oh yeah and it'll tell you when the
new episodes of the shows that you
follow are coming up you can leave
feedback you can make media your own if
you want to you can record reaction apps
you can record reactions to it all the
TV shows have been watching lately after
I'm done with every episode I like to
leave a comment about what I thought of
the episode really quick so you can
follow us on there we're at the real
rejects on TV time and seriously it's
like one of my favorite new apps to use
because I love the list of seeing the
shows that you're up-to-date on the
shows that you've completed this shows
that you haven't started yet but you
want to start it keeps it all very much
organized and easy to follow so you can
because there's so much TV out there
makes it a lot easier to keep on board
with and plus we don't review all the TV
shows that we watch so if you want to
hear our commentary on some things just
follow us there so you can see when
whenever we leave a comment on something
might even be for Jesse in the future
could be it really does who really does
clue you in just how much TV you want
even seen over a month and ten days of
television according to the Appetit all
done let's just take a moment and trying
I'm skinny I miss you I know I probably
shouldn't but I think about you all the
time I bet you do doctor what released
of people determine their own life yet
there's one force more powerful than
free will
[Music]
our desires
Jane you're just irritable sad for the
end of the night we go home daughter
lives and they lead there's you're not
getting at Washington area
Oh No Oh No Rohit they do where were you
really
aha so many bad days
I feel like I've been living my life as
two people
I don't know which one is real I am I
didn't control anymore
you control your [ __ ] impulses does
it make you feel powerful to manipulate
people like this sexual deviant yes the
psychosexual drama thing Wow oh man it's
like Mulholland Drive meets Fifty Shades
of Grey yeah and it looks provocative
they all right I I'm not a fan of Fifty
Shades I am I love you I thought in the
theaters opening day so much so not a
fan that I didn't even watch fifty
shades darker nor did i I think it's
cool that the director Fifty Shades is
the first one is doing this like a I
don't care what's cool about this one I
know it's Darren Taylor Johnson's life
yeah sorry yeah what's Kathryn Bigelow
okay so what what's neat to me about
this one I feel like they can be a
little more unrestrained with sexual
sequences yeah you know because to me
Fifty Shades of Grey holds back for what
it could be for a Netflix show I mean I
don't know any Netflix shows or movies
that go completely all out with its
sexuality I've been a very surprised
that they didn't do it here when that
seems to be the resonating theme of dark
sexuality throughout this whole trailer
yeah I haven't seen every original that
Netflix had done so I'm a little cloudy
on in terms of what their policy or what
their vibe is in terms of sexual stuff
but I mean this definitely looks like
they're intentionally pushing the
envelope with it yeah this this looks
like we get a lot of these movies that
try to be psychosexual so to speak and
it seems like in this environment this
is like a miniseries there is like I
believe so if we're going to explore
this this seems like a place to explore
it
I mean it definitely looks like it has
it's almost thriller II elements but it
seems like it has an erotic thriller the
psychosexual I feel like is the the
operant word because it is very wrapped
up in twisted psychology and oftentimes
that can be the sexiest form in
cinematic so making is when it when
something is wrong which makes it even
sexier yeah yeah the stuff that like
twists you up and then you know that
you're watching it happen so naturally
you get caught up and it makes you think
about not only just the physical
responses that you have naturally but
also just you know the the applications
to your own psyche I think sex is a
weird thing for us as a both in America
and just as human beings you know and I
feel like it's easy to get disconnected
between your body and your mind and so
that's a rumination I think it's
interesting the whole like for you in
control or your desires and communal you
know because chemicals flood your brain
oh it's a bleep totally then you end up
watching porn you don't want to yeah
we're all going out of it
College is manipulating your psychology
patient having sex with you yeah and I
like it I like the idea of that you know
I'm drawing a story as I go to therapy
John Goza therapy I know so many people
who go to therapy California kid yeah
California I feel like people in
California at least I don't know about
the rest of America or the world but I
feel like people in California are much
more open about how they go to therapy
now and are much more willing to just do
therapy
these will mean those people who just
absolutely refuse and don't want to do
it or don't believe in it however I you
know with it would therapy being much
more accepted I think as of a medium of
way to you know an economist yeah in
terms of therapy being much more out
there and apparent I love stories that
go down the path of therapy gone wrong
yeah yes I mean you've got real enduring
yeah the real thing transference happens
you fall in love with your therapist
there is also a patient because the
therapist gets so emotionally involved
it's I can imagine it could be difficult
for a therapist at times two completely
separate themselves and be indifferent
and just be doctor-patient which can be
a major challenge it's all about
emotions everything is just people it's
a lot of people
kind of interacting so you the rules we
setup and then the things that we agreed
to in the constructs and all that at the
end of the day it's still all just in
the hands of people get our green on
little thing that so yeah these kinds of
explorations or both I think have the
potential to be rich and also edgy and
you know we Naomi Watts I think is a
perfect actress for this tremendous
receives chris is an amazing actress in
general but specifically role like this
where you know she does a great job at
roles where the character is it seems
like a relatable regular human being who
goes down traumatic past and I think
she's strong at those roles huge
internal struggle yeah Billy Crudup as
an actor I'd always enjoyed watching you
know what I don't think is that good I
always enjoy watching Billy Crudup in a
wrapper for ages I think he should be
more famous he's more of one of those
actors where you have to be like in the
film to know who Billy Crudup is I feel
like Billy crubs one of those dependable
guys yeah he always shows up and then
for the most part he does a good job
even if the movies not very good and
Naomi Watts I think even to a higher
degree is like that works like even if
she shows up in something it's not great
she's usually great yeah I get up like
I've never seen her turn into like Lee
and Netflix those bold decisions so yeah
anyway I just got a notification on my
phone at the Black Panther trailer just
drop a little so this video is probably
going up after the Black Panther videos
already been up but subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell follow us on the TV time app on it
that's John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of blunt
house comm we got to do this